bir hasar Fransızca bir kelime
bu kanserin Türk Dil Kurumu'na göre
karşılığı incitmebeni Dokunma Bana demek
işte kanser Benim Yüreğime ne zaman
dokundu 40 yaşlarında henüz 40
olduğundan bile emin değilim henüz
kanserin Beni İncitme Mesih gerekiyordu
Aslında ta ki 21ocak kadar 21 ocakta
önüme bir kara paket kendi ve elime
Ceviz büyüklüğünde bir kitle
O hep otelim beş dakika 10 dakika ta ki
akşama kadar Akşam randevuya gittiğinde
ona bakar mısın Doktor hanım dedim
ultrasonla baktı yüzünün şekli değişti
seslitc ultrason yaptırdınız mı Kaç
yaşındasınız dedi ben size henüz kırk
yaşından 5-6 gün aldım dedim kırk yaşını
bitmemişti daha
bu daha çok vardı ve o gece yaptım O
gece rüyamda Ben kanser Değilim yanlış
bir kitle gelmişti elime
Sen hiç uyanmak istemedim saat beşte
uyandığımda Aynı duygularla baş başa
yaydım Sanırım ben kanserdim
arkadaşlarıma dedim ki beni bir süre
yalnız bırakın en sevdiğim otele gittim
O da tuttum odan içme yerleri
bu ne yapmalıyım
bu şaşkınlık ve önce içindeydi
bu alıyorum olmuyor ya düşünüyorum
olmuyor Balkona çıkıyorum olmuyor acaba
ben ne zaman olacaktım ne yapmam
gerekiyordu nasıl bir plan yapmam
gerekiyordu feda bir etmez Saydım devam
etseydim Aslında çok mu kısa süre
kalmıştı bütün bunları bilmiyordum
Bildiğim tek şey onların o gözlerindeki
bakışla benim ileri evre kanser olduğunu
da Ertesi sabah Telefon geldi Arzu
bizden haber bekle akşama kadar sonuç
çıkacaktır ki o gün benim için bitmek
bilmedi akşam telefon geldi Arzu evre 3
meme kanseri sin adenokarsinom Bu ne
demek dedim Eğer o kadar çok şey
bilmiyormuşum ki kanserle ilgili meme
kanserini o kadar tanımıyor muşum ki çok
genç olduğun için sana hızlıca
kemoterapi yapacağız 18 kemoterapi
planlıyoruz dedi Sen bu konu hakkında ne
düşünüyorsun
Ya ben hiçbir şey düşünmüyorum dedim ben
hepinizin Kız Kardeşim siz kardeşinize
Ne yapacaksınız ona onu yapın Ben
ilaçları öğrenmek istemiyorum Ben evreni
öğrenmek istemiyorum ve artık sanırım
yaşamak istiyorum ve ben ertesi gün
akşam tedavi olmayan kararımı vermiştim
bu yola çıkacaktım bu yolda mücadele
edecektim sonra her ne olursa olsun
Belki bazen ölüm belki bazen yaşam Ama
bu kararı artık vermiştim her tarama bir
şekilde bir dönüşüme vesile oluyor
kendinle ilgili bir dönüşme ben o
dönüşümü artık başlamıştım ve Ben
hayatımda ilk defa Onkoloji tedavisi
sırasında de kendimi mola verdim kendime
vakit ayırdım ama aslında Meğer ne çok
mutsuz biliyor musunuz 70.000 kadın her
yıl sisteme kanser
bu geliyoruz bu kanserlerin yarısı
45.000 imeme kanseri rahim kanseri
yumurtalık kanseri ve Rahim ağzı kanseri
da 18000 i yüzde 30.4 düşünebiliyor
musunuz her sekiz kadından birisi meme
kanseri olacak Hayatının bir döneminde
onunla tanışacak dolayısıyla her yıl
Sisteme giren 70 bin kişilik koca bir
aileyiz bu Türkiye gerçeği 2019 verisi
Peki ben o yeni ikinci hayatında ne
yapmalıydım ben çok güzel tedaviler
almıştım Çok uygun koşullarda
çalışmıştım çok uygun ilaçları
kullanırsın ya diğerleri diğer kadınlar
o 70.000 kadın ne yapıyor 45.000 kadına
ne oluyor hep bu soruyu sordum kendimi
bu sorunun cevabını bulmalıyım Çünkü ben
bu yoldan başarıyla çıkmıştım Ben
tedavileri mi olurken O bahsettiğim kız
kardeşlerim zaten böyle bir dernek
kurmak istiyordu böyle bir oluşumun
içinde olmak istiyordu
bir tek önemli Kriter vardı sağlıkta
fırsat eşitliği Biz benim yaşadığım o
güzel Tedavinin bir parçasını bile bir
başka hastaya Yakala ta bilirsek temas
ettirebilir sake hayatımızın en büyük
gururu o gülümsemeyi tanıttık
edebilirsek hayatımızın en güzel anası
olacaktı Keşke biz o kadınlara saçları
dökülmeden kaşları dökülmeden dokuna
Bilseydik Keşke biz o kadınlara erken
teşhisi hatırlatabilir seydik farkında
olabilse lerdi ama biz işte Tam da bu
gerekçeler de pembe izler kadın
kanserleri Derneğini kurduk Bundan sonra
her kadına yaratacağınız farkındalık her
kadına yapabileceğimiz tedavi bizim için
paha biçilmez mutluluk ve paha biçilmez
yüzdeki gülümsemeye s
ne olacaksa biliyor musunuz Türkiye'nin
herhangi bir yerinde Hiç tanımadığınız
bir kadının sizin için dua etmesi size
hiç minnet duymaması Sizin adınız tedavi
koşullarına ulaşabilmesi sizi ister
olarak maneviyata taşıyan bir duygu
diliyorum Bu başlangıçları devam ettire
biliriz biz küçücük bir aileydik bu
duyguyla yola çıktığımızda yedi kişilik
bir aileydik şimdi 90 kişilik bir
aileyiz bu 90 kişilik bir aile Bu
ülkenin neresinde olursa olsun bir
şekilde kadın kanseri olan bir hastaya
dokunmaya ona tedavi etmeye çalışıyor
Peki Biz neler yaptık bu yolculukta bu
yolculukta bir pembe Rota bulduk pembe
rotayla dedik ki ülkenin her tarafına
gidelim kadınlarımızı anlatalım
memelerini Tan
bu ve onların taramasına vesile olalım
pembe rotalar o kadar uzun Sürmeli ki o
kadar devam etmeli ki olabildiğince
hizmeti hastalarımızın ayağına götürelim
bin kadın oldu düşünebiliyor musunuz
1000 kadına ulaştık 100 kadını ameliyat
ettirdik yüze yakın kadına hayata
döndürdük Çünkü kadın anne Kadın ashk
adın Evren kadın kız kardeş kadına bir
şey olduğunda dengeler bozuluyor kanser
bana öğretti kanser teşhisi koyulduğunu
ilk gün
Bu bir ajanda yapmıştım kendime birinci
sırada eş dişi ki sırada ailem üçüncü
sırada sevdiklerim
34 yok V boşaltı birileriyle kahve içmek
7 film seyretmek Benim hiçbir hobim
yoktu beni besleyen ya da benim
besleyebileceğim sosyal faydalı fakat
dönüştüre bileceğim Şişli gerçeğim yoktu
biliyor musun
Ya ben şu anda o gerçekten alıştım
Sizden ricam konu sadece maddi değil
Çoğu zaman bir kanser hastasının yanında
olup sadece onu dinlemeniz bile çok
önemli bir kuvvet yol arkadaşlığı yapmak
bazen ağlamasına omuz olmak bazen Ağlama
duvarı olmak Bunlar o kadar önemli ki
bazen onun yanında şut kırışıklı dışı
örgü örmek onu kemoterapiye ve kansere
bakış açısını değiştirmek 21 ocakta bana
bir paket çıktı bu paketin içinden
hediye olarak kanser çıktı
ve o ana kadar olanlar Benim kaderimde
Ancak o andan sonra olacaklar benim
tercihlerim ve seçimlerim de lütfen siz
de bir gün size paketten kanser çıkarsam
sizin için doğru olanı seçin hem sizin
için hem de başka kadınlar için doğru
olanı yapın şükretmeyi öğrenin
başkalarına faydalı olmayı öğrenin Çünkü
başkalarına faydalı olmak hem Sizi hem
de başkalarını besleyen bir şey teşekkür
ederim